compared to other Wall Street Titans
like Lloyd Blankfein and Jamie Dimon
bobbum O'Shea is less recognizable
though you couldn't tell on the streets
of old Dubrovnik where people came up to
the hulking six-foot-four CEO to take
photos you can but I'm really nobody
while walking down these streets then mo
shaver called the very first moment he
took on the job of turning around AIG
when you first actually got your hands
on the books at AIG what was going on in
the company what did you see well I
didn't actually look in the books and I
had a pretty good idea of what was
represented by what's in the books
because I spent a lot of time with Jim
Millstein and Jim was the restructuring
executive was handling this for the US
Treasury and I spent a lot of time with
Sara Dahlgren who was also handling it
for the New York Fed they told me about
the financials I questioned them about
the financials and my assumption was
they did their due diligence when
Milstein and Dahlgren briefed you on
what was going on in a Geum what they
knew were the financials were they
better or worse than you thought in line
okay
but I thought that the world thought
they were worse than they really were
and you didn't I didn't think it was
that bad but it'sit's a question of if
the outside world thinks it's that bad I
gotta get you to stop talking about how
bad it is today AIG is a slimmed down
version of itself and profitable but
does it still pose a threat to the
financial system
I don't think another AIG will happen
we're not going to see another AIG
crisis again no I think we've been in
this position for over two years I I
don't think you'll see a bank failure
that we've seen I don't think you'll see
a securities industry failure like bear
or Lehman right now you give a thumbs up
to the regulators then I give a
thumbs-up to regulators for getting the
job done but I give them a thumbs down
for being afraid
to tell the public I've criticized many
people in Washington at all levels why
don't you talk about how much progress
you have made since 2008 their answer is
but we're not sure that something can't
go wrong and this is shame on you
because you should be sure I'm sure